foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today we're going to answer your
questions the call is free triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it Lydia starts this
hour in Orlando hi Lydia welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jade thank you for taking my
call sure what's up in your world
well I
owning the sdb bank failure
um
my husband actually works for a tech
company a small tech company in
California he works remotely
um but about one year ago took a job at
one of these small tech companies and
come to find out last week his company
was one of those that had their deposit
at SVP SCB Bank
we found out Monday that the deposits
are going to be backed by the FDIC and
the other insurances that the other
Banks I guess participate in so his
business is going to be okay but there
was a little bit of time there where we
weren't sure
but to give a little bit of back story
as well my husband and I started
following the baby steps about nine
years ago and we completely got out of
debt we're in baby steps four through
six and we even are going through our
first FPU class as coordinators so we've
never done it before and we're going
through his coordinators thank you
um yeah yeah thank you so much so um we
were able to kind of walk through some
of the principles with our FPU class and
we actually just went through the
emergency fund week and we decided to
beef up our emergency fund from three
months to five months because my
husband's job is a little bit risky as
far as little did we know tried
Institute company
um yes so we being in baby Subs four
five and six and just one year ago we
started
um really trying to tackle our mortgage
more aggressively than just
um you know maybe we we had been before
we just kind of gotten through debt and
then we were doing some other stuff in
our life now we're to the point where
everything's settled down we've we've
gone through that stuff and now we're
trying to pay off four five and six and
pay off our mortgage but because we took
this risky job we took what we were
paying for our mortgage and we started
putting it in like a side account you
know like this is the mortgage payment
but just in case something happens with
this job we still have you know this
this fund that we can reach into so uh
last month so that's that was one year
ago last month we saved up for a whole
year and we were able to save sixty
thousand dollars for our mortgage
we were last month I kid you not this
was February 23rd so probably only three
weeks ago we
um got news from his company that they
did a second round of funding and their
venture capitalist investors
um funded them enough to secure
operations for at least three years so
in addition to the sales that they make
this additional capital investment would
guarantee operating income for the next
three years and that would make payroll
and all of that so all of that money
that they had just gotten in February
was put into SCP Bank 100
so and we get the news we're sitting
here in February going this is great
news we have at least three more years
with this job it's time to reach and pay
off that mortgage or you know write that
check to the mortgage company so we did
February 23rd we wrote a check sixty
thousand dollars to the mortgage company
and then last week we get the news than
SVP bank then SVP SVP says hold my beer
yeah oh my gosh you may not be able to
make payroll and we have no idea where
this is gonna end up
um now you know we're about one more
week into it um we have a little bit
more information and a little bit more
security but I really just want to thank
you for the advice that we got on board
with you know almost 10 years ago
because now we were set up to be in a
place where even if he lost his job we
were secure yeah we have no debt except
our mortgage we only have uh or we had
beefed up to our emergency emergency
fund to that five month Mark how much is
left on the mortgage
uh we have about 400 left way to go
kiddo very good very good way to go I'm
proud of y'all well that's what happens
when you're when you're smart and you
and you follow the steps you have
Financial Peace that's right
that's right yeah I I was told we're
going to tell our FPU class here this
week you know we just went through the
lesson about the um
about the emergency fund that we're
really happy and dry under our large
umbrella
I love it we do to to the principles
that you teach we're very grateful well
we're grateful to you thanks for telling
your story and uh wow I mean that's uh
pretty incredible that's something I
love it it will rain Dave like it's
gonna rain you don't know what form it's
going to take but doing those steps and
having everything in order she was able
to you know even if he had lost his job
for a while they would have been just
fine yeah and it may take them a little
while to make payroll that's right the
Venture Capital firm funds it for three
years dumps all of that funding into
this bank it's a Venture Capital Bank
that's what it was mainly startup Tech
startups right and and VC money and even
some hedge fund money but there wasn't
much grandma CDs in there it wasn't like
regular people on this bank right this
is not your local credit union bank this
is not your your Regional Bank you
should be doing business with but um
yeah wow that's something so yeah they
Lydia didn't have any money in there but
her husband's company right his funding
was in there and boom you may keep them
maybe a little while before they get
that money that's true uh to be able to
make payroll but it doesn't matter she's
in good shape yeah that's great I love
that story thanks for sharing that Lydia
very very well done so here's the thing
we talk about this all the time and uh
Jade and I have experienced it a lot of
you have too that when you have a fully
funded emergency fund let's call it 10
15 20 35 40 000 whatever that is
whatever your rainy day fund is of three
to six months of expenses it turns
an emergency a drama filled and this one
was really Drama Oh yeah emergency into
an inconvenience that's right because
you know you're ready for it no one
likes let's be honest no one likes to
spend their emergency fund right it's
there and you're hoping you never have
to touch it but when that moment comes
and it starts raining and your job is at
risk or you know the car breaks down
water heater goes out roof blows off
that's when that money comes in handy
strange I remember one of the uh first
times we actually had a fully funded
emergency fund is a heating and air yeah
and you know what's weird is when you're
um when it has a big impact on you
emotionally the numbers stick in your
memory they do yes there's 3 842 well
that ain't bad because mine was five
thousand and two dollars a long time ago
okay okay okay okay
a long time ago dinosaurs installed the
new one
oh wow that's true though yeah you
remember you remember what you spent
that's for sure it locks in and and yet
it was only an inconvenience that's
right because every other time we had an
emergency there was a lot of drama
[Applause]
takes the drama out when you got
Financial Peace A
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us America hey if you're interested
enjoying the show would you do us a
favor
if you're not enjoying the show you
should go listen to something else but
if you're enjoying the show
do us a favor please uh obviously we
don't charge you for this and we need
your help we need you to subscribe to
the show or follow the show depending on
whether you're a YouTuber or a a
podcast on Apple or Google play or
Spotify wherever you are follow
subscribe Big Time helps leave a five
star review we don't anyone stars are
not helpful your mother said if you know
anything nice to say don't say anything
at all so move on if you're going to
troll just troll on and uh the the other
thing you can do is share the show take
a link share it if you're listening on
talk radio tell people where you're
listening if you're watching on TBN tell
them you're watching what time of day
how you're doing all this just spread
the word uh we just found out that uh on
Apple as an example we are the number 16
podcast in the world right now
out of uh millions of them I think
there's like two or three million
podcasts at this moment wow and uh we've
had over uh one billion downloads of
this show
so it's kind of crazy but and 100 of
that happen because you guys told
someone because we do not have a
football stadium named after us
we did not spend 300 million dollars on
Advertising last year
my allergies are bad but the uh um yeah
the uh we're just like helping people
instead of screwing them and uh so and
you guys tell people and thank you thank
you for that so uh check it out uh and
our guys really don't like number 16
around here on Apple they like want to
be in the top ten so I know that's you
guys will spread the word at least get
us to 15 for God's sake 16 is lonely but
yeah almost 15. there we go hey and Hey
listen every time you hear somebody do a
debt free Scream It's because at some
point they finally said I've had it I'm
not living like this anymore and a lot
of people out there today in this
current environment are scared
overwhelmed been there myself I know how
it feels
and if that's where you are listen it's
time to do something different you have
to try something new what you're doing
isn't working been there myself not
picking on you just time for something
new if you don't like the cake change
the recipe baby hey you gotta rethink it
and we'll show you how in Financial
Peace University our nine week nine
lesson course that's helped nearly 10
million people how to get out how to get
out of debt build wealth become
outrageously generous and we're gonna do
something right now that we haven't done
before in a while it's been a long time
right now go check out a sample of
Financial Peace University for free you
can sample it
kind of like those uh cool snacks at
Costco that's what I was just thinking
just think see it's for lunchtime but
there's that uh so don't go another day
with being out of control or scared Take
Back Control and get a free sample go to
ramsesolutions.com peace p-e-a-c-e
ramseysolutions.com would you like to
have some peace
everybody could use some more peace
financial piece two words that don't go
together like Airline service there we
go Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today Cecilia is our
Sicily how do you say it
definitely Cecily Cecily is in
Philadelphia hi Cecily how can we help
hi so it turns out my grandparents are
kind of weird people
people and I just discovered that they
left me or they're still alive but
um they helped me pay for a school and
I'm currently a student but they have
like a lot of money in the 529 account
and I have 10 grand in student loans
um just because I didn't know how much
was in it and now I'm wondering what to
do how to pay it off and how much is in
the 529
and I think after I finished school in a
year it'll still be like 130 000.
so my parents helped pay for college
except for that I I had 20 grand
student loans and I rolled 10 grand from
my 529 over onto the student loan so I
still have 10 grand left
how did you roll 529 money into a
student loan
there's a new policy where you can take
out 10 grand to pay for
student loan debt from a 529 one time or
per year
one time this was a new Biden policy
then you're going to also get a penalty
on the rest of it that you removed to
pay off the other student loan
the only other thing you can do is if
you under the new secure act which is
probably where that fell but I didn't
see that provision in it under the new
secure act
um I if you leave it alone for 15 years
you can roll it to a Roth IRA
and just let it let it sit there it's
going to grow put it in good mutual
funds and let it grow for 15 years
and then roll it to a Roth IRA which is
exactly what I would do with it other
than I would take enough out to pay off
the student loan once you're out of
school
mm-hmm so it's 15 years from when it's a
correct path yep no no from
um uh 2024 I guess it's from your
graduation is okay
I don't know I don't know what the start
date is on that I don't know whether
it's when the uh 529 was formed or from
when you graduate but it's uh basically
if you keep an 0529 around long time it
can be rolled to a Roth IRA and it
effectively as a Roth IRA anyway because
it grows tax-free so you can put it in
good mutual funds just like it was a
Roth Let It Grow and just pretend like
it's Roth money uh and then roll it to a
Roth whenever the appropriate date is
and you'd have to get a little more
research on it
would I be able to put it in like kids
names you can you can use it for kids
you can use it for siblings you can use
it for spouses use it for anybody
anybody anything you want to do and it's
15 years from the date it was opened
James just looked it up and said that in
my head in my ears in my ears
it is 29 years old so well I think I
think you can roll it to a Roth now then
uh so what I would do with it is
um what's your degree going to be in
Social Work masters of social work
okay what are you planning to do
uh medical social work okay what does
that pay
um upwards uh 85 to 10 100 if I'm doing
well okay so medical social work's
obviously a different field then okay
good yeah I mean it's the same degree
but if you work in specialty that's what
I'm in here yeah the specialty is where
the money is going to be okay good so if
you can roll out making 85 I wouldn't
touch the thing at all I would just pay
off your student loans with your income
okay when you get on don't don't take
out any more obviously use the use the
529 to graduate with no additional debt
pay off your debt out of your income and
then this becomes a Roth IRA when you
graduate
wow okay that's yeah that's exactly what
I would do if the if James's information
he just pulled up uh from the
trustworthy internet
um is accurate then uh then this is
already eligible because it's 15 years
from the time it was opened that sounds
right that sounds like what I read
it doesn't make sense though because if
you have a four-year-old
15 years later they're 19. and then they
can roll it to a Roth
that sounds weird but there's listen
it's the Biden Administration it's the
IRS nothing here that's predictable so
all things are possible yeah be sure you
check all that out and make sure you've
got that right but uh because it's all
brand new number one number two we don't
have the details
um and we're Googling it as fast as
we're talking here and that's about it
but yeah so but the concept is there 15
years after some date you'll be able to
move it to Roth if that information is
correct then the the way I parlayed
that'll just work that'll work for you
but since you only got 10 grand if you
had 60 Grand in student loans I'd
probably use some of the 529 wouldn't
you I would yeah there'll be a penalty
on it
yeah but I think it might be worth
getting rid of getting rid of it as a as
opposed to the time it would take to pay
it off yeah
yeah
because that's what that money is for
for school you know I would not cash out
your Roth IRA for a penalty no way no I
wouldn't do that well it's similar
mathematics is the problem
but um but the the Roth IRA is that's
gotta it's got a brand on it as far as
I'm concerned do not touch right where
529 really is earmarked for paying for
school even if you took a penalty
because your weird grandparents didn't
even bother to tell you you had 150 000
bucks sitting there
oops I forgot to tell you
twenty thousand dollars they said they
were weird so she did she meant it she
did they're definitely asleep at the
wheel
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
one of the ways we learn stuff on this
show as hosts is we screw stuff up
so during the break we dig into this uh
Roth IRA conversion from 529 stuff and
you found a site what's the name of the
site this is just U.S news money okay
money.us news and we hope that's right
it's a good site I use it quite a bit
okay well it's talking about the the new
Provisions from the secure act 2.0 and
the last caller was talking about what
can she do with 130 000 Roth 130 000 529
I told her she could roll it to a Roth
after if it was 15 years old yeah which
she can the Roth the 529 has to be more
than 15 years old but you can only roll
35 000 limited lifetime so she can't
roll the whole amount and not only that
she can only roll uh up to the annual
contribution limits for the Roth IRA so
six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars so it takes six years to put
thirty six thousand thirty five thousand
dollars in there yeah and you're not
doing your Roth while you're doing that
that's right because you're maxing it
out out now so that would change my
advice then I would tell her instead to
use this for her kid yeah because you
can use it for your children unlimited
and the spouse is unlimited and so since
the whole role it to the Roth IRA thing
is so pinched down and bottlenecked in
other words this is the Washington DC
and going look we did something oh wait
when you get into the details it's not
worth a crap okay and that's kind of
what that is
choked it down so far it's useless it
was a great idea yeah it is able to do
this could encourage people to save
money but by God the IRS wants their cut
so yeah you're not going to get to do
much of whatever it is and then then you
know the politicians strut around act
like they did something well it's making
the assumption that you wouldn't
contribute to a Roth IRA on your own so
you have to use this to move it over I
mean but why not just let the whole
thing roll over if you're going to do it
that's what we thought it was yeah that
was a good idea but I don't know I don't
know oh no all right in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Christian and Christine are with us hey
guys how are you hey where do you guys
live near Lynchburg Virginia all right
welcome good to have you been up there a
couple of times speaking at Liberty and
so uh good to have you guys with us how
much debt have you paid off
936 yeah and how long did this take
about four and a half years good for you
and your range of income during that
time 83 000 to 138 000. excellent what
do you all do for a living
so I'm the director of operations for a
Christian non-profit and I'm a professor
of nursing at a local University ah cool
which one liberty
strangely enough okay cool well good
good
well we're big fans of Liberty around
here and uh so 157 thousand dollars
director of nursing was that a student
loan yes okay yes yeah okay not such a
big fan of Liberty now all right so uh
the whole thing student loans so three
of it was cars that was about twenty
thousand the rest was our student loans
mostly mine but how long you guys been
married it'll be ten years in January
what happened after five years I gave
you the wake-up call and said we're
getting out of debt yeah so I was on
maternity leave with our oldest and um
Murphy hit the house and everything
started breaking like our car our HVAC
and our fridge the fridge was the last
one and I remember sitting there with
her on my chest and they had just called
and said it'd be 250 to fix the fridge
and I pulled up my bank account to see
if I had enough money because we had no
emergency fund like we were both working
full-time but still like had nothing and
but we literally had nothing we had 30
dollars in our bank account and it was
that oh it's gonna spoil yeah yeah and
so
that was kind of the moment I was like
how do we have full-time jobs and good
careers and not have anything to our
name I love it and so um we were Dave
ish for a while because we had a newborn
and then we got pregnant again with our
second and then it wasn't until after
our second was born that we finally hit
it strong and did it what made you turn
up the heat to turn to hit it strong
doing that we wanted to be able to
provide for them and just also just just
weighed us down like we couldn't do
anything we felt like we felt like we
couldn't do anything without getting
more debt and so we but we didn't want
to do that so well and she as she said
we you know we both had full-time jobs
we were working hard and it felt like
you had nothing uh you know you you go
you work your 40 hours a week you come
home and all the money is going to
someone else so how did you actually
find out about you know baby steps Dave
Ramsey Financial Peace which one was it
uh it was a church we were attending at
the time
um and now the church we're we're
coordinating at the church we go to now
cool yeah very good lots of fun very
very cool Thomas Road
they did a church-wide Financial Peace
University John Pastor Johnson was a
friend of mine and I went up there and
spoke when they did that and so uh a lot
of the major churches have done
church-wide fpus and so anyway cool very
good guys so the church comes along with
FPU just the time you guys needed it yes
yes essentially yeah and now you're the
coordinator to do that for somebody else
yes wow having a great time with it and
our our fbu classes really excited that
we're here and we we let them know we'd
be coming over to to do our screen I
love that yeah that's fun so what was
the big Catalyst did you start was it
that you started budgeting did you have
to do any side work like how did you
broke it Loose yeah so thankfully we
didn't I mean we considered side work
but we didn't have to we just figured
ways to one grow our career but before
that it was definitely a budget like we
sat down that first budget meeting
probably was like three hours long and
we were not happy with each other at the
end of it
um
yeah
yeah but I mean it's true it was not fun
to like figure out you know but after
doing it just several months we had more
money than we realized when we finally
told it where to go and so just keeping
that budget like every single month and
now it's like I'm the nerd of it so I do
the budget and it's a couple times he's
like can you add this in the budget but
it's like a five minute thing no I love
that that's how it goes the budget the
budget Reveals All yes so very very cool
yeah it's not actually doing the budget
that's hard it's all the stuff it
reveals yeah yeah when you first start
it's like God I'm stupid you're not
you're stupid we are stupid it just
where it wears you out man it's just
it's like I'm horrible very clear mirror
it is a mirror yeah and then you feel
like you got a raise yeah you really do
yeah way to go guys way to go very proud
of you how's it feel to be free weird
yeah it's awesome we were talking to
someone earlier and uh and we were
saying how the month after we paid off
our debt you know we looked and we were
just like oh we don't have to give this
money to anyone like it's our money just
to now start putting into baby step
three and start saving we don't it's no
one else's money so it's weird yeah very
cool it does it's a little bit surreal
yeah almost it's like you come to the
other side of it you're like uh I feel
like there's something I'm missing yeah
yeah I feel lighter and I will say
because it was four and a half years it
felt like such a long time like you hear
people getting out of debt in like 18
months and two years and like just with
our incomes at the time our incomes
didn't grow to what they are now until
about a year and a half to two years ago
which really was kind of the driving
force to finish accelerated yeah exactly
but like in the middle is when it was
the hardest so at the beginning you're
like excited in the middle you're like
should I keep going this is so hard and
then at the end it's exciting again
because you're almost there so like for
people that are in that middle like just
keep going because it's so worth it you
will get there it is possible that's a
good point because you got enthusiasm
when you first start I'm going to get
this and then you get in the middle it's
a slog and then when you get to where
you can see the light at the end of the
tunnel it's not an oncoming training now
we can Sprint to it exactly exactly
exactly that's a good that's a good
analogy well I think we did a we did a
good job of you know some months it was
harder for her and I would be there to
encourage and no no it's worth it let's
just let's get this done and vice versa
the there were times where I'd want to
you're in that slog and you're like you
know what if we don't do it for a couple
months and we go do this instead and we
you know we're able to keep one another
in check and work together on it when we
had like a chain countdown he made um
you know like the chains he put that in
our kitchen perfect and I like kitchens
like my place and I was like it's so
ugly he was like well the day it's
terrible I picked the worst colors I
picked the worst colors let's bring the
kids up and introduce them right quick
before we run out of time and I want to
make sure what are their names and ages
Rita 7 and Luke is five right you know
how you were real proud of you guys we
got the live and give box for you with
the baby steps millionaires book Total
Money Makeover book another Financial
Peace University membership for you to
give away congratulations Heroes well
done thank you very well done Christian
and Christine from Lynchburg Virginia
157 000 paid off in four and a half
years making 83 to 138 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream because
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how it's done yeah this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America this is the Ramsay show hey if
you're new to us and a bunch of you are
because our ratings and our listenership
numbers are going way up quickly thank
you for that if you're new to us uh and
you're just trying to figure out what
all this baby step stuff means and where
do you fit in and it's uh all this debt
snowball stuff go to ramseysolutions.com
click on the get started button it's
completely free we're not going to
charge you anything and you can figure
out where you are now and what your next
step is and we'll start explaining it
all to you and customize it for you so
again
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
Christian Is With Us in Greensboro North
Carolina hi Christian welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh yes so I was calling because
I had a question I have uh six million
dollars worth of uh property here in the
area and
um uh oh almost three million dollars
about 2.8 million in uh in loans uh my
question was do you think it's wise to
sell some of my portfolio to pay off the
loans and be debt free or should I
utilize the monthly cash flow to pay off
the loans uh fast what do you think
well congratulations you've done a good
job you got a good Equity position
and you've obviously got a going concern
and uh you there's a lot of different
ways to attack uh the situation where
you are you can keep doing more of what
you've been doing
um here's what I learned when I had uh
when I was 25 years old 24 years old I
had four million dollars worth of Real
Estate
and I owed three million on it so I did
not have as good an equity position as
you do
okay I was about about 75 loan to value
you're about 50 all right but I ended up
losing everything
because the bank got sold to another
bank called our notes we had a lot of
flip notes out on 90 day notes and it
caught me and took me out
and what I learned from that going broke
process in my 20s 30 years ago was that
those of us that love real estate people
like you and me Christian uh sometimes
we forget to measure risk
Common Sense tells you an actual
business analysis tells you that the
more debt you have the more risk you
have would you agree with that
yes indeed okay and what I've discovered
now over 30 years not only of teaching
these things but of living a completely
debt-free life and I today on several
hundred million dollars worth of Real
Estate
um and uh what I've discovered in that
process building that portfolio a
different way over this 30 years is that
the lack of risk
with having no debt
has accelerated over the Long Haul the
amount of real estate I can own
because I don't make as many mistakes I
don't have setbacks I don't have cash
flow problems I've always got cash
can you imagine how much cash my real
estate throws off with no debt
it's obscene okay and uh so but and
that'll I can buy another piece of real
estate with just cash flow fairly often
it uh because we've got tremendous rents
coming in on these things now so all
that to say what I have learned from my
personal walk and from walking with
others is that where where I know you
will be the best off in 10 years and
have the most wealth because of the
lowered risk and the increased peace in
your life
um
is if you were debt free now do we have
to burn everything down and do this
suddenly because you just you and I had
a conversation no I think you have a
gradual process and you say okay over
a year two years three years whatever it
is I'm gonna move in that direction
because if I were in your shoes I would
rather have four million dollars of paid
for Real Estate than six million dollars
of real estate with three million
dollars worth of debt
is very true and that's about where you
all be because your real estate will go
up in value while we're doing this
all right so how long you've been doing
this apparently you've been doing it a
while and you're good at it
well I've been doing it since uh 2012. I
actually used my W2 to help me purchase
property and I was also flipping at the
time yeah okay and uh it was 2019 I
decided to uh leave my job because I was
able to sustain
myself and uh yeah and all the bills
yeah and so you're doing flips in
addition to this
maybe two three times a year okay uh
yeah but it's good pocket money okay
yeah you can probably live off your
flips and then your your other stuff
just generates income that's awesome
well done good for you well here's what
I figured out when I'm doing a flip I
buy something differently
if I'm paying cash
and when it is paid for I am in no rush
to sell it
so my my I never become a motivated
seller or a motivated buyer
and I get better deals on the buy and I
sell for higher on the sell
because I got all kinds of patience with
no payments
but when the payment's eaten you're
eating your back pocket out
it makes you want to jump and get rid of
that thing you know what I'm saying
exactly and I've been following you for
quite a while and uh I would like to be
debt free at some point uh that's why uh
have you got any properties that are
higher LTV that are 80 90 LTV
really really low I mean you're at about
50 on the portfolio if what if you don't
have any that are higher than that
they're all about 50 percent
okay
that would be the first ones I divest
but since you don't have those what I
would do is just look at the portfolio
and go okay 10 years from now which one
of these suckers do I want to own
oh and start going okay I'm going to use
some some cash flow and knock out a few
and I'm going to liquidate I don't know
a couple million dollars worth or
million dollar million and a half worth
or whatever it comes out to be and you
know between those two things have a two
or three year plan to be free
because again you're gonna you're gonna
be wealthier and you're gonna have a
better life if you start with four
million dollars of paid for Real Estate
three years from today
I'm not arguing with that
got a I think he got the nice day
version of that that was great well he's
he the reason is is because he's
actually pulling it off yeah he's not he
he could probably survive
and not and do and you know 10 years now
you start doing there's nothing down
real estate crap on Tic Tac uh you're
not gonna survive 10 years yeah that's
right all the guys that I knew doing
that in any generation have gone broke
including me so uh but he's sitting in a
50 Equity position so he's gonna cash
flow and if he manages the property well
and he's been doing it a decade already
yeah so that tells me he's really got
his crap together but now we're down to
the symbol of philosophy is you start
asking yourself is this debt-free thing
really better and the actual end result
of the data is yeah you end up better
not just a better feeling right you end
up with more money well yeah you laid
that out really clearly I think that he
has a a good strategy for him and
something that he can start walking
towards which is really cool you know
those of you that are playing with real
estate or want to play with real estate
let me just tell you something
you will never put in you will be less
likely never you can always do something
stupid you will be less likely to put a
bum tenant in a property when you don't
have any payments
but when you got payments you're looking
for somebody to pay those payments with
their rent
and you're you're more desperate as a
landlord to fill your vacancies and
you're more likely to go well I know I
kind of had a bad feeling
turns out she was doing drugs who knew
wow but you know I mean whatever it is
right and you put a tenant in there
that's a bomb and then you've got a mess
they tear up the place you go through
you still go through six months with no
income you go through an eviction you go
through all this stuff bankruptcies on
them everything else it's a mess but you
won't Overlook that if you're going
I don't think unless you really make me
feel good that I'm going to let you have
the privilege of living in my property
because I don't have any problems now
and I don't need you to bring your
problems to me that's such a good point
yeah so you just desperate landlords
make stupid decisions like this for
people of any kind and ends up costing
them more yeah and yeah you get you do
get you get bit you get really bit and
I've done both I've been both it's been
a long long time since I've put in a a
weak tenant
because I had to because I haven't been
there in decades now and so I'm just
really encouraging folks there's a
there's a way to do this real estate
thing where it turns out really nice and
there's a way to do it where you go
broke so and Christian's in the middle
this is a good question this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jay
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phone's a triple A
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Natalie is in
Fresno starting off this hour hi Natalie
how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
hey so my husband and I just started
listening to you I needed something to
listen to while I was doing cardio and I
found her show
and I told him he needed to start
listening and so we just decided to
Crunch the numbers and I guess what we
had been doing was ignoring
kind of what the debt was because when
we added it all up now it seems awfully
overwhelming and
um yeah I don't know I just found out
I'm going to lose my job my company sold
and they're getting rid of all of their
remote workers
and I'm at home with our four children
and I homeschool them and so I don't
have the ability to just go get another
job
so it was kind of
um
adding fuel to the fire and we're not
sure where to go from here or how to
tackle this mountain that we've created
how much debt is it
um we currently owe 80
881 dollars
hey I want you to take a deep breath
because you I can hear in your voice
that you're just you feel overwhelmed
you feel worried you feel stressed you
don't know if there's a way out of this
I can hear it
um you sound like actually you're on the
verge of tears which I've been there
that feeling of just kind of sweeping it
under the rug and not looking at it and
I know for my husband and I we just kept
putting it on forbearance and putting it
on and then when you come back to it
it's like oh my gosh how did it get this
one you've officially had an oh crap oh
yeah yeah so what kind of dead is the 80
um so the majority of it is in a home
equity loan
um that makes up about half of it we
also have a solar loan and actually very
little of it is in credit card debt
there's also another small loan but all
of those are no card the credit card
debt
um we have a small loan on a car yes
okay what's your husband Mike
she makes eighty three thousand what do
you make
um I was bringing home about between 800
to a thousand dollars a month so it
wasn't astronomical
but it was just kind of something that
we weren't expecting to lose my income
um you know in the midst of like hey we
should get out of debt
and now it just seems almost impossible
we're finding the work from home workers
are the first to get laid off
schooling right
yes so I I just wanted to check are you
homeschooling by default because you got
laid off and you thought okay well now
I'll just do this or was that originally
the plan
yeah I know I've been homeschooling my
kids from the start
um I have sixth grade
um fourth grade and second grade
currently and our youngest is just one
how much is your house payment um
um it's
1481 dollars awesome okay yeah yeah okay
exactly I'm with Jade here um yes I can
hear that you've had this thing and it I
can hear the uh emotion that comes with
an oh crap moment but I can also tell
you uh if you guys are willing
to go bananas I mean go crazy where your
broke friends are making fun of you type
of stuff for about for about three years
we can get you a hundred percent out of
this I can show you how you can do this
but you're gonna have to get real
different
you're gonna be living on half of what
you make now yeah you're gonna be you're
gonna be cranking and you're gonna go
pick up some side gigs that you do from
home there's stuff out there you can do
for a thousand dollars I thought you
were making 50 or 60 Grand work from
home or something the way you were
talking but no you can go pick you can
go pick up some side stuff and um just
something else to work from home he can
look at picking up OT or something else
you all can look at what you can sell uh
and then uh you're you're going to be on
a scorched Earth
nothing
budget
you have enough clothes you don't need
to buy any more budget you're not going
out to eat you're broke people broke
people shouldn't go out to eat you're
not going on vacation you're broke
people broke people shouldn't go on
vacation you're going to clean up the
mess so you're not broke people anymore
because it's no freaking fun to be where
you are right now agreed
yeah and we just got done with a no
spend month my husband had a mission
trip planned
this month so
um he kept that because it was already
paid for before we started this but we
definitely we've been trying to
just cinch wherever we can and our kids
are feeling well your your whole your
whole life for the next three years is
going to be a no spin month you're about
to have three no spend years and that's
baby step two and you know I I just have
to add this to it you've had your oh
crap moment of like this sucks I don't
want to live like this but you gotta go
now to the next step of what's the
greater why and you need to start
envisioning what your life is going to
be like if you do the things that we're
telling you to do I wouldn't be like to
have no payments because if you don't
connect a greater why to this I tell
people all the time the stronger the why
the stronger the try so if you have a
very strong why you are going to do your
best you're going to work your hardest
and you're going to stay motivated
through that three years those three no
spend years so that you can achieve that
Vision that you have in your head you
know so you and your husband are gonna
sit down and you're gonna do a detailed
written budget every month where every
dollar has an assignment it's called
every dollar it's the world's best
budgeting app we're going to give it to
you we're also going to give you
Financial Peace University our nine-week
class that has helped 10 million people
do what you're getting ready to do and
the two of you you and your husband are
going to sit down look at this and
you're going to start to dream again and
you're going to lay it out and you're
going to cut everything even further
than you thought you did when you did no
spend I mean and then you're going to do
anything you can do to get your incomes
up that's legal and moral we are going
to go bananas and uh for three years if
you'll commit three years to live like
no one else later you're going to be
able to live and give like no one else
you won't ever have to save up for a
mission strip again you can just go
yeah
yeah that sounds awesome thank you guys
you can do this you can do this Natalie
it's hard today but each each step that
you take you're getting closer to a life
that's fine that has Financial ease
right now you're in The Angst moment if
I give you this Financial Peace
University can you get your husband to
sit down watch his first lesson with you
on board and then and then download the
every dollar app as soon as you get off
the phone and it goes right in there
with it we're going to give you the
advanced version so you can use the
every dollar up as tied to your bank and
it's going to be really really easy to
do to keep up with the budget and to
start it but the thing that's going to
be hard is you guys are going to
dramatically change your lifestyle
because you're now going to tell your
money what to do instead of wondering
where it went
because you've been living like Congress
for too long
and you got to break the cycle and it's
painful to break the cycle but it is
worth the price because you're going to
be free you're going to be free would it
be like to have no payments
I promise you this will work hold on
Austin will pick up we'll get you signed
up for it
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you are here uh Austin is in Atlanta
Georgia hey Austin welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey thanks for having me sure what's up
hey uh me and my wife we bought a home
in 2020 it's not our forever home but it
gets the job done uh let me get the baby
step six should we continue to focus on
paying down the home or build a nest egg
to assist with our forever home and plan
on building in about five to eight years
from now
I mean if I were you Austin I would
continue paying down I mean well let me
find out where are you in the baby steps
she says six
okay
maybe so four five and six you said
right
yeah so we're we're uh we're on step two
right now but we're we're looking to
have all that done within the next eight
to ten months uh I'm doing long-term
planning okay how old are you
I'm 27. okay uh let me help you with
this there's no such thing as a forever
home except heaven
forever home is just an excuse for
people to spend more and and do do the
most yeah I mean you can do whatever you
want to do buying a home and you're
still going to move again
I mean there's a lot if you build it at
68 years old it might be your forever
home but other than that your life's
going to change and you're going to move
again so that that's a concept that's
just completely bogus so anyway aside
from that just pay off your house
because here's the deal if you're going
to sell the house and move up in house
which is really what you're saying
that's fine I got no issue with that at
all but when you sell your current home
and it's paid off they're going to give
you a check for the whole thing
it's not like you're spending the money
it's not gone you're just paying off the
mortgage
still there in equities that make sense
yeah yeah so pay it off and then that
gives you more options and then sell it
and they're going to give you a check at
the closing use that check to buy the
next house that's the upgrade home right
because here's the other part of that
people put a nest egg aside and they
think I'm just gonna sit on top of this
money for when the right time comes and
then before you know it
Uncle boo-boo he's had he's he's having
a uncle who uncle boo-boo is in
everybody's life that's when the wedding
in the Caribbean comes
wedding in the Caribbean comes
a real estate project he wants you to
invest in
Uncle boo-boo tells you to buy
cryptocurrency everybody has one day
this guy's evil
he is he's got a horrible name too
but everybody's go everybody's got one
and and he's the one that steals from
that that nest egg that you say oh I'm
gonna save this for my forever home yeah
something always pops up so when you go
ahead and pay off your mortgage on bass
boats are on sale yes see that's Uncle
boo-boo Uncle boo boo bass boats too he
tells you to go buy it he gets around
he's like he's like the boogeyman of
Finance I Love It uncle boo-boo who knew
yeah
another Jayden another Jayden it is all
right Malachi's with us in Princeton
Kentucky hey Malachi what's up
uh yes thank you for having me on your
show Dave sure how can we help my my
question about it is is I finished baby
step one now I'm on baby step two I'm
actually moving away
um
I'm going
back to uh my hometown and
my ex-wife I co-signed with
um on her student loans and on her car
the student loans are 7 621 they have
offered me that's gone to collection
they've offered me a five thousand
dollar payoff
and if I were to do that first instead
of taking care of my smaller loans which
I know that you say you know you pay
your smallest loans off and you move on
to the next and the Max and the next
but
would you you have five thousand do you
have five thousand dollars
again yeah five thousand dollars
it's five I do not what are you gonna
get it you're gonna have to pay it all
at once
okay because the offer is not paid
because if I were to get that off you
don't have five thousand dollars
yeah these deals only work and they're
usually for a limited time for a lump
sum for a lump sum
yeah because I'm I'm whenever I'm moving
I'm looking for my full-time job right
now
um but I've already got my part-time job
lined up I'm in the National Guard I've
been in there since 2018. yeah so I'm
gonna be pulling three jobs getting my
kids every weekend because I'm paying
1200 a month in child support
and
we used I actually I took your class in
high school
um I had ten thousand dollars I had a
800 and
30 credit scores
and so you must have not learned
anything in my class okay
yeah well I had um
I got with a girl and she I got her
pregnant and um now I have three kids
and now we're divorced I've actually
been separated since July it got
finalized in February I'm sorry um
uh I got this new place in um in
November and I've had to ask for money
from
family members and stuff like that
because all this debt that we had racked
up
um for the life that she had wanted and
the divorce decree was she supposed to
pay the car in her student loan
yeah
actually my lawyers and her negotiated
um because it was so much
for the student loans I'm responsible
for half
for half of the seven thousand because
her car would be refinanced after that
got out of collection into her name
completely and that would give us a car
out of your name okay yeah so yeah yeah
yes you do need yes you do need to pay
the student loan and yes you do need to
negotiate a lump sum when you have a
lump sum but right now Malachi you don't
have any money
yeah so I'm actually I'm moving back
into my parents home so right now what
you're going to do is you're going to
get on a detailed budget you're going to
live on nothing you're not going to go
out at night at all you're going to work
all the time and you're going to start
paying these debts off and when you can
get enough debt paid off that you you
know you pay off the little ones and
that'll get you more cash flow because
you're paying payments on all this crap
except her loan you're not paying on her
loan actually I am sir
I thought you said it was in delinquency
it is
um
here lately I've been I've been directly
sending it to her yeah so stop her house
yeah so stop sending her money and stop
sending student loan people money tell
them where she lives
yes sir they already know yeah tell them
tell them to call her I'm the co-founder
there I know they're hounding me I know
just tell them jump in a creek you're
not paying it
I'm broke okay I'm broke I'm divorced
and I'm broke I don't have any money I'm
not paying it I'll pay it when I've got
some money how much other debt have you
got not counting this mess
um I've gotten down from or I right now
as of uh today I have 410 and 1 or 410
yeah and one credit card uh 239 in
another the car that I originally bought
for her that I got throughout the
divorce is 13 354.
um so twenty thousand dollars twenty
thousand dollars makes you debt free
I want you to go make twenty thousand
dollars in the next six months extra and
be a hundred percent debt free
and cut up your credit cards you cut up
your credit cards your car her student
loans
everything completely different I want
you to work like a maniac right now this
is all happening to you and I'm trying
to get you to happen to it there is not
a technique that fixes this except money
and you get money from working more
yes sir and that's what I'm that's what
I'm doing I'm actually you're about to
start but if you don't have any money
right now and you don't even have a job
right now
yes sir I've I've been on contact with
phones I've already got one part-time
job there you go that I'm going to be
doing after my full-time job good I'm
doing the National Guard and I'm gonna I
just got done with the interview today
as soon as all this money starts coming
in pay off those little credit cards and
then save up five thousand dollars and
call the student loan people and offer
them five thousand dollar lump sum until
then don't give them any money
that offer is going to continue to be
good yeah because I mean it's in
collections now just call them up and go
I can give you 5 000 now if it's two
months from now uh they'll take it all
right and then that clears that then all
you got left after that's your car
and then I want you to pay that off in
about three months
and really you should be debt free in
six months you're living at your parents
house you got no overhead it only takes
twenty thousand dollars to pay off
everything but all this crap has been
happening to you divorce kids a lot job
loss people calling you and hounding you
everything's happening to you and it's
time for you to stand up and happen to
it and start telling this money and
these people what to do instead of doing
what they say to do it's time for you to
bust this thing in the nose and you're
about ready to do it I can hear it but
I'm telling you this is how you get
after it get it get it
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on that debt
free stage Brian and Elizabeth are with
us hey guys how are you hey Dave hey
Jade welcome welcome where do you guys
live Littleton Colorado oh the Denver
area huh cool good to have you guys how
much data have you paid off 244
000. wow wow how long did this take 56
months good for you and your range of
income during that time we started out
at 156 000 and we ended at 225 000.
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
I'm the executive director of a
non-profit I manage a member Care
Facility ah very good guys very cool
good for y'all so what kind of debt is
this 244 it was a little under 20 000
was student loans and the rest of it was
our mortgage
yay weird people totally weird no
mortgage yeah way to go YouTube what's
this house worth uh about 7 45 days wow
I love it and how much you guys got in
your retirement accounts um right about
520 right now
baby steps millionaires also wow how old
are you millionaires I am 46 and
Elizabeth 43. wow not even 50 years old
wow that's exciting ding ding excellent
job we wanted to pay off the house
before I was 50 was my goal we blew that
out of the water he sure did yeah just
blew it a big time yeah all right tell
us this story what got you guys started
on this Ramsay stuff well uh I do a lot
of driving for my job and I was driving
south of the Denver area and found you
on good old-fashioned radio if it was
God's hand because I lost the Denver
radio station and picked up some
Colorado Springs radio station and uh
heard some guy talking about these baby
steps and I'm thinking what is he trying
to sell me and I don't know KRDO
Colorado Springs you got it that's the
one that's the one and
um so I I I love nerding out to this
stuff I always thought I was good with
money and I knew what I was doing and
these baby steps weren't jiving with the
stuff that we were doing
um and so the more I listened I heard
you meant Financial Peace University and
I saw that advertised at our church and
so I connected the dots I said okay this
is what that's all about so I came home
and I asked Elizabeth I said would you
take this class with me the next time
it's uh advertised at our church and she
was initially a bit hesitant yeah the
word budget to me meant restriction at
that time
um so yeah I was a little hesitant yeah
but the sell point for us though was the
fact that we weren't getting any
traction we both had really good jobs we
had good income we were playing these
Financial gymnastics at the end of every
month we were pulling from our savings
to cover our expenses for the month and
then promising ourselves the next month
that we would replenish our savings
accounts you're Americans
so that got us into the class and we
started taking the class Dave and
um unlike unlike a lot of people we just
went all in I mean both feet we just
jumped into the pool we didn't dip our
toes in uh we found ourselves Elizabeth
you kind of came in a little bit like I
don't want to do a budget don't tell me
I can't do stuff and then how long did
it take before you were like both all in
I I want to say it was probably the
third class because that's when we wrote
the check so yeah wow so check for for
all of our debt those student that
student loan debt oh yeah paid it all
off yeah we had consumed we had a little
Nest Egg built up she had enough to just
knock out your dad it might be step two
that's right so we had our thousand
dollars set aside and then every it took
everything else that we had saved up to
go into baby step two yeah yeah it was
week two week three and we just we got
it all taken care of was that scary to
do oh my gosh we felt so vulnerable like
a lot of people go go gazelle intense
and do their debt snowball on two we
were in this place where we had nothing
to fall back on so ours really kicked
into three we did the math on how long
it would take us to get three to six
months of expenses and we weren't
comfortable living in that space so we
we went full bore we went crazy I
started slinging packages for Amazon she
started picking up uh work doing dog
sitting I was I was flipping lawn mowers
I was getting free off of Craigslist I
like that one that's good we were people
just give away free stuff and we're
flipping we were just going nuts did you
build your baby step three yeah so it
took us um the majority of that time
that I was working for Amazon about
about 11 months that got us through 2018
and 2019 rolled around we found
ourselves in baby step four five and six
and
um
the life hits on the side of the head
real hard we were doing good and we were
so thankful for FPU and your lesson on
insurance and knowing that there's this
defense that you need to to go along
with the offense and I'm so grateful for
that for that message Elizabeth did all
the work she made all the phone calls we
found out that we were underinsured in a
lot of areas we got ourselves an
umbrella policy we had a new 16 year old
driver in our household we've got five
kids three living at home right now and
woefully underinsured with liabilities
we got all that stuff put in place and
we're so grateful and
it would be put to the test
we ended up my son had a tragic accident
that took the life of an individual and
severely injured another one
um so we had to not only navigate trauma
stress and of course mental health but
we also had to navigate legal matters
um but one thing that we did not have to
navigate was our finances yeah because
we had
um the setup for the defense we
finalized our last lawsuit
um last year wow
um and we were set up for financial
success we stayed in the program when
the accident happened hold was her son
16 16 and so he's like 18 or 19 now he's
12. okay how's he doing he's okay now
he's still in mental health yeah that's
a process to go through unbelievable
yeah I mean it's horrible the the other
family had the loss obviously
um but people don't realize that that
um 16 year old kid that's got to absorb
this yeah and work through it that's
that's traumatic so we're navigating all
that but Dave we didn't have to worry
about money
um that's the one Saving Grace that we
had and it was really just looking back
this is all God's hand right just amen
guiding us to all this finding your
radio station getting this stuff in
place and not exactly random that you
land on the radio station no not exactly
random at all and so yeah we uh you know
we we restarted our 401ks after that
point baby step four because we had
stopped those to get emergency fund
built up we started 529s we were late to
the game but still were able to get
enough in there all of our kids have at
least their first full year of college
going in state paid for to kick start
them and every last dime went to the
house we just stayed gazelle until we're
freezer burnt food out of our freezer I
mean we're wiping off dust off the cans
in our pantry oh that's where to eat
yeah all that stuff in there yeah
that is something man so what's next for
you guys you've got a paid off Home
Mortgage you've done everything that you
can do what what's your what's your live
and give moment well I can tell you that
uh we drank the Kool-Aid of Dave Ramsey
and we've actually we're wrapping up our
10th course that we have taught thank
you
thank you wow that's something and we
are going to Ireland
I love it what cities do you know yes
we're starting off in Dublin we're gonna
do a 10-day tour we're gonna go to South
Killarney and then we're going to end up
in South
um Ireland so yes okay very very cool
beautiful it is a beautiful trip
yeah yes we will gonna pour the perfect
pint when you're in Dublin for sure but
yeah way to go you guys yeah very good
good I'm so happy for you thank you
sorry for what you've been through and
I'm really happy that uh that God's
timing sets you up to walk through that
amen yeah
now very very cool well done he rose
Ireland I like yes I like it that's
going to be a great a great trip good
stuff all right we've got the live and
give bundle for you guys uh it'll all be
give for you because it's the baby steps
millionaires number one best-selling
book you already are so you can show
someone else how to do it same with The
Total Money Makeover and the same with
the Financial Peace University
membership so you'll have good use to be
able to pay that forward on all of those
we're honored to have you with us here
today so proud of you thank you very
proud well done what a great story and a
great process that you guys plugged into
very very cool Brian and Elizabeth
Denver Littleton Colorado
they paid off 244 000 house and
everything baby steps millionaires
weirdos 56 months making 156 to 225 off
to Ireland count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
love it love it love it well done
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five well there's a lot of questions
about taxes right now it's tax time and
we all hate it
I stay perpetually angry during this
time
and uh so let's unpack a question from
one of our listeners Dave we have a
cabin we inherited years ago we're
thinking about selling it since we're
older it's getting harder to keep up is
there any way to get around capital
gains taxes
uh well for this scenario there's three
ways to help reduce capital gains tax
sell the cabin as soon as possible the
longer you wait obviously it's going to
go up more tax you're going to owe you
can move into the cabin make it your
primary residence for at least two years
you will lose the primary residence
exemption on your personal home though I
wouldn't do that or you can rent out the
cabin and when you do eventually sell it
you can defer the capital gains by doing
a 1031 from one rental property into
another but you'd have to have at least
one year that the primary use of the
cabin was a rental
and so if you rented it for a year then
you could uh you could do a 1031 and
roll the which is a tax deferred
exchange it's called and you roll the
gain into the next deal if you wanted to
do all of that other than that you're
going to pay Capital Gains here's what's
interesting it may not be that much
the the value of the cabin when you
inherited it
is your basis
and so go back in the year you got it
what was it worth
that's what your everything above that
will be your capital gain of course
minus expenses and so if the cabin was
worth 150 000 when you got it
now it's worth two hundred and ten
thousand two hundred twenty thousand and
it costs twenty thousand dollars to sell
it in expenses
you'd have a two hundred thousand dollar
net minus a 150 basis would only be a
fifty thousand dollar gain at fifteen
percent it's only three thousand dollars
in taxes
so you're probably you know depending on
how it all works out I don't know the
value when you got it or the value today
but um I honestly wouldn't go through
any of that other crap I would just um a
lot of Hoops to jump through to get
three thousand dollars back if that's
what it is if it is a three thousand
dollar Actual taxes yeah and um but but
sometimes we hear you're going to get
capital gains tax and we go into we
start doing stupid stuff just and then
you if you ever write it all out and
figure out it was fourteen dollars you
know I was getting ready to do I was
getting ready to be stupid for 14
because we got all this emotion because
we hate taxes so bad yeah I hate taxes
the only thing I hate worse than taxes
is financial stupidity mm-hmm
and I have done and I've seen people do
Financial stupidity to avoid taxes
and that's what you don't want to do so
I I would actually calculate out what
your gains going to be after expenses
versus what you paid for or what the
property was worth when you inherited it
and then figure out what your taxes are
and then they'll tell you the direction
to go Jennifer is in New York City hi
Jennifer welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Jade thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can we help my
husband my husband and I um we have no
debt except for two income property
mortgages our primary residence is paid
off entirely the total Mortgage Debt
combined on the income property is
approximately five hundred and eighty
thousand dollars
um one of the remaining mortgages is two
hundred and eighteen thousand the other
is 366
000.
um so we're thinking of unloading the
one with the 366 000 balance uh using it
to pay off the two hundred and eighteen
thousand dollar balance
um
so the reason that this is a question is
because they're both very profitable
properties
um each property earned a net income of
about 50 000 each annually so about a
hundred thousand combined a little over
um what's your household income
income is 250 000.
so how quick can you pay off 550 if you
keep them both
so whiskey Zone intensity we project to
have them both paid off within three to
four years the idea of having the
rentals paid off for in a few years is
definitely appealing okay um it's also
appealing though to have your head hit
the pillow debt freeze tuner rather than
later but wondering your take on giving
up you know such a cash generating asset
because it's essentially like there's no
there's no there's no wrong answer here
there's no in neither cases your face
going to appear in the stupid column
okay yeah so if you want to sell one and
be dead free head hit the pillow tonight
that's the right answer if you want to
pay them off over three or four years
that's the right answer the wrong answer
would be one you didn't mention which is
I think being in debt for rental
properties is wonderful and I'm going to
stay in debt my whole life right that
wasn't that one's not on the table and
so for you or for me or for Jade it
sounds like you like both of the both
the properties if you were saying that
the the property that's 366
000 you hated it and it was getting on
your nerves and things like that then
yeah maybe sell it and take it to pay
off property number one but you said
they both generate great cash and I
liked what Dave said I mean you can pay
both of these off with your cash flow
and then you're gonna have three
properties that you own completely full
out including your personal residence
that's amazing if life changes
so I want them true that
I mean you can you can change this
decision
um I personally if I woke up dark Hotel
Ballroom moment do what now
we thought maybe you know the mortgage
that is like our dark Hotel Ballroom
moment how you talk about in your book
that we were kind of brainwashed into
thinking you know oh you know if you
were brainwashed if you decide you
wanted to keep it around like it was a
pet uh and so we're we're just
discussing whether it's reasonably wise
to get rid of it in three or four years
or instantaneously neither answer is
wrong how old are you
we're 38 years old both of us and um we
we have a really really strict budget
um and you know we have about 30 000
stage four rainy day and we both put 15
to the 401K so we've got about 300 um I
have 360
000 in mine my husband has about 300 in
his so 600 and um almost about 650
combined
um there's not a wrong answer but it
sounds like I'm just there's not a wrong
answer between the two that we were
talking about but it sounds like it's
bothering you a little bit to keep it
around and if that is it bothering you
or are you just afraid you're being
stupid
afraid of being stupid yeah that's us
you're not be you're not okay we would
tell you if you were yeah if you call me
up and said I want to go into debt to
buy rental property of course we would
tell you enough but you're here you can
clean all of this up you're millionaires
you're 38 years old you're goal-oriented
people you're very intentional with your
decisions and your decision-making
paradigms and I don't hear anything in
here that sounds anything close to
stupid that's what I mean by your face
is not in the stupid column so if it I
and unless I hear something different uh
you know and talking with you for
another 20 minutes or something I would
tell you to keep them and pay them off
in three to four years
make sense makes sense to me but if you
want to do the other that's okay too
that's okay too but you're not stupid
for paying them off in three to four
years you would be stupid to say I'm
going to keep the debt around forever
and then you can open up a Tic Tac
account
all right Julia uh wow see here's the
thing this is so funny to me you know
the old Ecclesiastes uh the word says
there's nothing new Under the Sun yeah
and I'm getting old enough to where God
man bell bottoms are back
I own a pair and so is nothing down real
estate oh
I mean everything comes back around
you mean you mean these guys have to
make that up I think Beanie Babies are
coming back I mean everything seems to
come back around nothing down real
estate since I've been on the air in uh
32 years now has gone through three
major Cycles
the cycle right before I went on there
that I went broke in
I lost my tail and nothing down real
estate then there was another big one
with the cable TV midnight cable
infomercials sitting by the waves
selling you a cassette tape set on how
to get rich in real estate Dave Delgado
who now makes actually really good wine
in Napa and he's got a wine called the
beast that's incredible but uh yeah he
made all his money made all his money
selling tape sets by the waves and now
this now the Tic Tac Generations just
running it crazy in a little slime balls
running around all over Tic Tac trying
to get you to go into up to your
eyeballs in debt because all real
estate's good debt I mean every I mean
Dave Ramsey doesn't know you really
really all this crap yeah
yeah that's the way it works y'all the
way it works it goes in Cycles even
stupidity goes in Cycles but that's true
Jennifer is not on that list no she's
not not on the stupid list this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Matt starts
this hour in Orlando hi Matt welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Jay thank you guys so much
for taking my call sure what's up
um so I just wanted to kind of see what
you guys thought what could be my my
steps in my process here
um I took a different job in August of
last year
um both the job before and the job now
have been commission based and I was
supposed to make around the same amount
of commission but unfortunately I'm
making about half why and
so I do
um like uh trades work so basically I go
around quoting jobs and getting them
sold and
um if I'm being really honest I think it
might be the marketing side that's not
we're not getting the amount of calls in
that we should be
um so I'm just not making as much uh as
many sales as I use what is it you're
selling
um electrical work uh panel Replacements
you know rewires that type stuff for
residential homes well construction
stopped
no construction stop it's just that we
do primarily residential service calls
so I don't know you know were you with
homeowners
yes oh I see okay for electrical
problems on a home you go to their house
is that what you were selling before
yes
and it was just a different company uh
the company that we got before uh do you
know anybody selling stuff at your old
company
yes are they you're still making if
you're struggling as well they've been
struggling as well so it's not the
company it's smart it's the marketplace
yeah probably
it's not marketing then
if your old company was is not making
what they used to make and you're you
know you're you're not making what you
used to make at the new company it
sounds like and you're in the same field
it sounds like the marketplace has
slowed down with the economy slowing and
inflation and people watching every
dollar and all that kind of stuff
actually 100 agree with you okay uh but
there's there's like a wide variety of
other issues but I'm not gonna you know
fit into details on that but yes
Marketplace has definitely slowed down
is this job what you wanted to be doing
long term
yeah actually
uh yes this is I love it this is my
career
um just been in the electrical field in
general
um you know I just I love doing
electrical work for sure well in the
meantime is it possible for you to pick
up some other work in order to kind of
close that Gap income wise
the biggest issue with that is
um you know we work under our license so
I wouldn't be able to do work
um on the side without a license not
electrical work but you could drive over
yeah yes so actually I do pick up that
work
um my schedule is a little bit varied
you know
um I can't get I wanted to get like a
consistent you know after hours job but
my schedule was so inconsistent you know
I'm out maybe 12 13 hours a day
sometimes what are you what are you
making
um on average take home a month is
around four to five thousand a month and
you were making double that before
close wow okay probably about 30 yeah
okay so here here's the thing my friend
Henry Cloud wrote a book called
necessary endings
and he says you need to end
a relationship a process a job
when you would lose hope
that there's any chance it's going to
get better
okay and so if I'm in your shoes I've
got to decide how long am I willing to
wait for this to turn before I need to
call it a day and switch careers
um
and I don't know how long that is how
long do you want to give it
um before you know at this rate versus
the double rate that you were making
before before you're willing to do this
how long are you willing to ride this
storm out to stay in this field
um Let me let me help you it's not five
years
yeah it's it's not it's not three years
right
you don't want you don't be sitting in
the same soup three years from today
correct so just keep you know is it one
year is it nine months is it the fall
if it didn't fall but if we hadn't
turned it by Fall we're gonna go look
for something is it one year this time
next year if it's not we're gonna hold
my breath hold my nose and fight through
and work the extra job the weird jobs on
the side just so I can stay in this
field hoping it's going to turn back
but at the point that I lose hope that
it's going to turn back I'm out of here
and you need to set yourself a date
certain
because that will relieve a lot of your
anxiety the uncertainty of this could go
on forever is runs down your spine and
rests in your lower back
and you know I gotta believe that
there's other job opportunities that use
a similar skill set that use some of the
same you know things that you know how
to do and enjoy doing so you might want
to start researching that but the screen
says that you're behind on your debts
how much debt do you have
uh I am without the mortgage about
seventy five thousand dollars in debt
all right so that's letting us know what
what Dave was just talking about your
necessary ending that's got to come
sooner than later because if you are
sitting here debt free and you just
called in and said hey my job just you
know my income just got cut in half what
should I do you would have you could you
could extend that time period but you've
got a lot on the line here with seventy
five thousand dollars 75 on
a lot of dumb stuff super tax as you
call it yeah one of them credit cards
that are maxed out
um it's from primarily this transition
just trying to keep everything afloat
and it's how much how much your car debt
by credit card
uh I have one car and it's about five
thousand like no four thousand all right
so your car is not your problem okay
yeah so is it what is most of this debt
credit cards oh credit cards and uh we
did some dumb stuff with some affirm
stuff okay and but but you're done with
that now right
no that's that ends in August no no I'm
saying you're done using never clicking
on easy payments again
100 yes I'm not let me affirm trying to
work on the baby steps right now
let me affirm you that a firm is stupid
yeah here here's what I wanted here's
what I want to say to you a year you're
going through something tough but I'm
here in a
I'm hearing a lot of excuses I'm hearing
a lot of butt and well and we'll see the
thing is and I I need you to understand
that right now you got to make a change
right now you got to change it
there are a lot of times where there's
reasons that things are going wrong and
things are not going well but I want to
challenge you to cut off that point
because at a point the reasons start
becoming an excuse and I don't want you
to cross over to that excuse Zone
so now's your chance to start making
those choices start making those changes
like I said research jobs that earn more
that use your same skill set they're out
there they're there check out Ken's book
paycheck to purpose Austin can you give
them that book that might help him out
to find something new for him but look
this is your moment to change no one's
going to do it for you no one's going to
hand you a job no one's going to come in
and pay off this 75 000 of debt but you
Warren Buffett says when the Todd goes
out you can tell us who was skinny
dipping so this lowered income has
revealed that you were living chaotic
and out of control and now you get the
opportunity to fix that this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
Live Events are kicking up and
jam-packed and sold out everywhere but
we're going to tell you where you can
come if you can still get a ticket
Building Wealth we're going to be April
the 24th in Salt Lake City Utah with
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Christine
Ellison me May 2nd will be in Anaheim
California with Dr chandeloni Ken
Coleman Christine Ellison me
Jade was at the first two that we did
and we've also brought back smart
conference and we kicked it up a notch
this is our first uh weekend version of
smart conference uh Friday afternoon
we're gonna do the Ramsey show this show
right here live We Do It live on the
glass anyway here but we're gonna do it
live from the Ramsey Event Center the
brand new Ramsey Event Center from the
stage and we're going to have a huge
audience in there to do that we've got
other stuff planned through the
afternoon we've got a neat uh time with
the audience uh Friday after Friday
evening and of course some of our
friends from Nashville are going to join
us we're the music business here and uh
some names you'll recognize are going to
come hang out with us and we'll have a
little Nashville moment and then
Saturday all day Jade will be speaking
Dr John deloney Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
George Campbell me we're going to go
through everything from mental health to
jobs to uh goal setting to just winning
with your money and the details we're
going to go into every part of your life
and this is the inaugural event the very
first event at the new Ramsey Event
Center I was up there today we're
looking at some items we're installing
today it's absolutely I'm so proud of it
it's absolutely stellar and we've
announced Ken Coleman's career
breakthrough events they're going to be
in Kansas City April 20 Chicago May 16
Atlanta May 18 Dallas Texas May 23rd oh
I forgot the smart conference is April
14 and 15. uh one month from right now
that's right and there's a handful of
tickets left us all for that weekend
event at smart conference Ken's uh Ken's
career breakthrough just went on sale
it's got the money and marriage event
with deloney and Rachel next fall all of
these things are at ramseysolutions.com
events our events lately have well for
the last 12 months or so have been 100
sell out everywhere we go and so if you
want tickets you need to get them to all
of these things they're going quickly
they always do Juliana is with us she is
in Phoenix hi Juliana how are you
great how are you better than I deserve
how can I help
good so my first my husband and I are
just wondering um if we should approach
an HSA account more as savings or more
of an investment based on where we are
at the baby steps where are you at in
the baby steps
um where four and six we don't have any
kids currently but we'd like some in the
future is the
HSA above and beyond the 15 that you're
investing into retirement
um yes so we're yeah we're investing 15
and 401ks
um we want to at least get our max out
of pocket in the HSA just to cover
medical expenses but we're not sure if
we should keep contributing after that
yeah it's not going to matter that much
uh in a given year it will matter over a
period of years
um uh
yeah I would keep doing the HSA as long
as you're doing it in addition to the 15
percent
and uh once you get to a certain point
make sure you get with someone like a
company called Health Equity is one we
use to flip your HSA money into mutual
funds once it gets to be substantial
because see the way the HSA is going to
work is as you know the health insurance
is with it is a high deductible but it's
a low max out of pocket
and so what ends up happening with the
HSA is the HSA works best the math works
best if you're very healthy or you have
chronic
uh chronic health problems okay like
I've got a friend that's got Crohn's
disease and so he's constantly hitting
his deductible and his max so the HSA
with having the lower Max is much better
for him because his max out of pocket is
less and in an annual basis and so even
though the deductible is higher but he's
always going to hit his deductible
because he's always dealing with some
kind of medical something and uh on the
other hand you've got Sharon and Dave
which uh and you know hasn't seen the
inside of a hospital we don't know what
it looks like we visited some people
there once but that's all and so uh you
know so what happens with us is we never
even have a medical expense much less in
a deductible and so uh our HSA I started
doing it when George W bush put it into
place the first time I've never touched
it
consequently it's all in mutual funds
and it's several hundred thousand
dollars because it's been a long time I
never I don't need it it's become
another investment vehicle so those are
the two extremes obviously that can be
there but but yes I would go ahead and
do that at this stage uh I wouldn't go
crazy with over funding it or something
I'd rather get your house paid off but
yeah definitely get it up to where
you're covering your deducts and oh at
least double that kick it on up there a
little bit I mean get 20 30 000 bucks in
there but but you don't need 300 000 in
there not have paid off your house
on the other side that's what I do yeah
you're doing that too that's what I'm
doing I like having you know some people
you have your three to six months of
emergency funds but I liked having the
the deductible and the HSA so that it's
just another thing that I don't have to
touch no I would not do that if you're
in baby step two or three facts yes
that's true you don't have your
emergency fund in place you don't need
to be putting a dime in an agent that's
correct yep you need to build your
emergency fund and be debt free before
you put money in an HSA this is baby
steps four five and six so really really
good stuff there very well done all
right our question of the day comes from
neighborly your hub for Home Services uh
this company is incredible they if you
need to make repairs or schedule routine
maintenance find local help for Home
Improvement projects and neighborly is
your source for Reliable home service
providers in your area things like Mr
Electric Mr Rooter Molly Maid names that
you recognize like that uh go to
neighborly.com and you can start your
search to get some help help with things
around the house all right today's
question comes from Lucas and their
Ramsay baby steps Community you can find
that on Facebook he says I just recently
got engaged my fiance is bringing ninety
six thousand dollars of student loan
debt into the relationship I am debt
free and I've been saving up to buy a
home so far I have ninety three thousand
dollars saved I know that once we're
married her debt is also my debt so I'm
wondering do I take the money I have
saved for a house to almost pay off her
student loans and then get back to
saving for a house or do I buy a house
and then get intense to pay off the
student loans oh boy okay Lucas here's
hard it's hard but here's what I would
do if I were in your shoes you're this
is your fiance it's not your girlfriend
So the plan is that you're gonna get
married and you know that that's coming
around the bin what I would do is keep
this money this ninety three thousand
dollars set aside the moment you put a
ring on it the moment you say I do you
guys are essentially in baby step two
well baby step one you'll keep a
thousand of this for your a thousand
dollars saved and you'll put the other
92 000 on her student loans and then you
guys will pay those off you'll save up
three to six months of expenses and then
and only then will you go to baby step
3B and start saving for a home down
payment and I know when I said that you
got a lump in your throat you might have
lost your lunch a little bit because
you've been saving for a long time but
that's the story of that's the Glory of
Love Dave that's the cost of putting a
girl in it okay
in this case
I should say putting this girl in it
yeah I feel his pain he you know this is
this is who you brought this is um
yeah
it you know when you look back on this a
thousand year 100 years from now 500
years from now 20 minutes from now you
won't think anything about it but at
this moment at the moment you write that
check right after you get married you're
going to be going I'm gonna kill you
that that
song some somebody knew somebody knew my
reference you got to give a little take
a little let your poor heart break a
little that's the story yo that's the
Glory of Love there you go so his heart
is his heart is breaking because of this
and uh I feel for you Lucas but that is
the right thing to do just go ahead and
don't don't get the house first even
though you're like man I've been saving
because if you get the house first
you're gonna get married and then you
guys are gonna be in debt and it's not
going to be fun uh living there
I got to tell you this is also going to
make you
triple check in your pre-marriage
counseling that this lady isn't going to
swear she's going to never borrow money
yes
because if she thinks she's going to go
back in debt after you do this I we got
other problems we know the problems so I
mean she's got to go
we're never gonna but I'm never even
gonna walk near a credit card I'm gonna
walk near a car lot with a car payment
I'm never going to ask you to go into
debt ever if she can't make that kind of
a pledge and make you believe it you've
got other issues yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade Warsaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America this is the Ramsay show in the
lobby of
resolutions on the debt-free stage Dia
is with us haker how are you I'm good is
deja Deja Vu yeah okay I'm sorry thank
you for correcting me because I would
have messed it up for the next 15
minutes okay okay where do you live I
live in Chicago South Side welcome to
Nashville good to have you how much debt
have you paid off 80k all right good for
you and how long did this take it took
me two years it would have took me a
little bit less but I kept starting over
and starting back again so yeah two
years all right and what was your income
during that two-year uh 50k okay what do
you do for a living I right now I work
for Uber
um I actually work for their
headquarters and sales but back then
when I was paying off my dad I was
working in retail as a store manager for
Foot Locker okay good for you okay so
tell me about this uh tell me what got
you started on of this two years ago and
then while you're at it Go and tell me
about the start and over part yes so I
um actually follow Asia dang she
actually came here and she was on the
podcast as well and once I graduated
college I was just like oh my God I have
so much debt I had 13 credit cards Dave
13. just because I just did not know
um anything about money I was not taught
um how to manage money I was just like
oh credit card you gave me this amount
that's free money but I never really
understood interest and anything like
that yeah that part we have to pay it
back yeah absolutely right I was like
wow I got to pay this back I thought she
was trying to give it to me
um but yeah so I would pay off something
I would congratulate myself and then I
would
go back into it just because I was like
oh these jeans or these shoes I really
want them
um and I just it was just back and forth
back and forth and then watched Asia she
paid off 200k in two years so for those
of you don't know she became an
influencer while doing her debt-free
journey and then following our stuff and
then came down here and did our debt
free scream I didn't know she's like a
star yeah absolutely and then she came
in and I'm like I just was in the
presence of royalty and I didn't know it
yes yes so yeah for that she actually
put me on to you and then I just
listened to the podcast every day going
to work
um I would like just turn on the podcast
and I would just hear all these people
saying like oh I paid off my house I
paid off this I paid off that and a lot
of the people that I was surrounded by
um just was not doing the same things
that you know you were preaching and
coming from a low-income family
um strictly minorities it was nobody was
talking about it it was just like why
would you pay off day you're gonna live
it like literally people would tell me
you're going to die in debt so why are
you trying to pay it off so just hearing
that I was just like oh dang
um but I finally did it you know and I
actually paid off my last bit of debt it
was my last student loan people were
telling me like don't don't do it you're
gonna the government is gonna give you
the money back and I'm like I am not
about to wait on this government like
okay I'm just not I'm just not about to
wait on them
um so I paid off my last student loan on
Thanksgiving day and I was just I was
just so grateful it didn't hit me until
I called Don and I was just like I would
like to do my debt-free screen and then
I cried I love it yeah very good thank
you I'm proud of you thank you so now
um I get the uh on and off again off on
and off again and I really appreciate
you telling that story because a lot of
times people that happens and then when
they get on the debt free stage they
don't want to tell that part yeah and
they really did do that
um but uh so I appreciate your uh
authenticity on that the
did you reach a point though that you
were saying now I'm just on not not
going to be tempted by these jeans again
I'm done I've gotta I gotta do this yeah
absolutely it was so my original debt
when I first first started was 40 40K
but I actually added another 40K in debt
because I was just adding credit cards I
was just doing so much dumb stuff and I
just did not have the people the right
people in my corner to like motivate me
and keep me on track and then when I
realized like you just got another 40K
in debt and you don't even have a house
you don't even have an apartment if you
know what I'm saying like you're still
living at home with your mom and you're
25 years old and it was just
embarrassing and I was just like you
know what this has got to stop
um there it is and yeah I just it's the
behavior it's the behavior change so
yeah we're doing the right things with
money but you hadn't changed your your
full Behavior everybody knows pay off
your debt do this but you had to get to
the behavior part love it yeah whoo so
what was what was the the how was what
was your response to all the haters
because I know there are folks out there
on the haterade like oh you know yeah
you know why are you paying off your
student loans how did you respond to
that because that's everywhere right now
by the way
um I it was it was coming for my family
it was coming from a family you know
family has a weird way of just like
saying something that I just make you
change your entire mind
um and they weren't doing it so I was
like you know what I'm just gonna be the
first in my family do this I was the
first in my family to go to college I
was the first in my family to you know
pledge a sorority I was the first in my
family to do all these things I want to
be the first in my family to be debt
free and then I'll come back and I'll
you know I'll get i'll get my mom I'll
get my sisters you know I'll get my
brothers and then we'll get all on track
um so I think it was just trying to
block it out and just listen to the
podcast truly like the podcast was the
my best friend and then also praying to
God because Lord knows I have been I
literally was just horrible with money
so it was just tuning it out and just
keeping going and then once I
highlighted everything off I was just
like you know what you're that girl you
did it you did it wow I bet your
family's proud of you now I bet now
they're wondering how did you do it yeah
absolutely that's exciting that's
exciting good for you well done very
well done the uh
the power of your family of origin
number one uh the neighborhood you grew
up in me too yeah uh the power of that
and the power of the people you
currently decide to run around with that
you make the people that are influencing
you
um you you speak like them you read the
same books they do you develop the same
values uh you uh even you'll even adjust
your accent to fit and
um uh it's human nature yeah be not
deceived uh deceitful company corrupts
good habits scripture says and so when
you hang out with a deceitful company
when you hang out with people who are
doing the opposite of what you want to
do you it's come it's very difficult
today you brought that up three or four
times yeah as you were talking about
this and so it's just but it highlights
it it's very very important to you've
got to put new inputs into your brain
you're gonna put new things into your
brain to get the junk out
and um I got a good friend that grew up
in really really rough
circumstances and he's become very
wealthy but he said you know getting out
of the hood was easier than getting the
hood out of me
and uh that's a that's a that's a saying
what we're talking about I mean you got
these tapes that play inside of us from
the way we grew up you know people like
us you know or I always heard a little
man can't get ahead you always heard
well you're gonna die with that you know
and these these are all these they don't
mean to be negative but they just like
Eeyore is their spiritual animal yeah
they just don't know they say what they
know yeah that's right yeah that's all
they know and it's just but now they
gonna learn something different because
of you yeah yeah even broke this chains
yes well changing my family tree there
you go well done very good up down or
sideways is good good with me on that
tree however you want to get at it I
like it very well done I'm proud of you
thank you good work good work
congratulations all right now when
someone asks
all you've been through and on again off
again but finally on what is the key to
getting out of debt
um I would probably say
the budget for sure making sure that you
actually know what you owe
um now that I'm like helping I actually
have my own business now it's called
budget box life and I'm helping young
minority
um students who are in college and going
to college helping them to know exactly
what you owe and taking it from there I
feel like if you don't know if you're
too scared to look then you're not going
to ever know you know and it's just I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you a case
of Total Money Makeover books yeah okay
we'll ship them to you she had to carry
them on the plane so we're also going to
give you the baby steps millionaires
book The Total Money Makeover book yeah
University is your gift thank you for
being here but we're going to help you
with the next 26 I think and it's in a
case or 24 is in a case something like
that we'll give you a case of them uh
and we'll get you shipping information
and send it out to you thank you
congratulations all right Deja way to go
from Chicago 80 000 paid off in two
years making 50k count it down let's
hear it debt free scream three two one I
[Applause]
did that's how it's done
love it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus spoke to the people once more and
said I am the light of the world if you
follow me you won't have to walk in
darkness because you will have the light
that leads to life
Corey ten Boom said now I know in my
experience that Jesus's light is
stronger than the biggest Darkness
and she had that experience without a
doubt open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Sherry is in
Detroit Michigan hi Sherry welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you very much thank you how can
we help
so um my husband and I we've been
following you for probably five or six
years of following the baby steps and
it's allowed us to get to step six
pretty quickly so we are now in a
position recently where we could uh
finish paying off our mortgage or
um I mean we just refinanced about two
and a half years ago for two and a half
percent so we have a really low uh
mortgage rate
what made you what made you decide that
following us was not a good idea after
you've been following us
I just
our families like we've you know both
come from families like without money we
don't know anyone that has money if we
are not in a position I know but you
followed us all the way through until
you got here
well until you know we you know have a
lot of people talking to us saying hey
well you know you followed us and did
everything against everyone everyone
says to do and did what we said to do
until you got here
you follow you understand yeah
yeah
and now suddenly
now suddenly we we don't know what we're
doing
[Laughter]
I'm picking on you Sherry pay off your
house girl
okay
so you know just
the only thing you know we keep going
back and forth with our mortgage rate is
so low and get something returned
greater but I know okay and you're going
to stand out the rest of your life and
you're going to be normal like all those
people that you were doing
yeah stupid stuff both before
okay I think this is what I needed here
yeah get out of debt finish the baby
steps but you know okay don't get to
baby step six and turn left
see it through
and when you're debt free 100 house and
everything you'll have control of your
most powerful wealth building tool
you're going to have a level of
financial peace that you've never had in
your entire life and maybe that none of
your friends have ever had and maybe
that your family has never had you're a
hundred percent debt free at that point
how old are you
uh we are 35 and 36. oh man and so
you're going to be multi-millionaires if
you just take your house payment and the
old payments you used to have and start
investing those
how much is left on the house
I don't want 50. oh yeah come on now
come on and get it and then when you're
done you'll be able to invest to your
heart's content
and be unreasonably generous too yeah
yeah don't don't quit now you almost
you're almost there don't give up at the
end
you know almost to the end and then all
of a sudden two and a half percent
sounds like a good idea to stay in debt
a lot of people do that they get they
get through the the hard part of the
race and then they're they're 10 the
last ten percent is there and they quit
don't do it Kelsey's in Wichita Kansas
hi Kelsey how are you
excited to talk to you guys you too how
can we help
dollar emergency fund we are in the
process of trying to get rid of our
stupid toys that we don't need
um and so we have a travel trailer that
we currently owe about 43 000 on we have
an outright uh by offer from a
dealership for 33. oh good so about 10
000 less than we owe good however and
and I can take out you know a personal
loan to cover that difference
um but if I do that the interest on it
is going to be 10.75 and it's on a 58
month payoff for 250 a month you're not
gonna be in it for 58 months though
it'll be like four or five months to pay
it off yeah yeah so you're not even
you're not even gonna pay five percent
right the other
the other one six or six months of a ten
and a half percent annual rate is five
percent
true yeah
yeah the other option that we had is
there's another dealership that will
consign it nope
no you would go ahead and go get rid of
it consign it is you still own it and
you hope they sell it before they sell
one of the own their own off the lot
here's the thing the the beautiful part
about this let's walk through here why
am I going there so fast all right
I like ten thousand dollars in debt a
lot more than like forty thousand
dollars yup all right I like getting rid
of a camper which goes down about as
fast or faster than anything else with
wheels
if you screw around with this thing
sitting on the consignment lot for 10
months it might go down another ten
thousand dollars
right and we can get rid of it and then
downgrade our truck that we don't eat
anymore stop the bleeding we've stopped
the bleeding it's done it's over the
story is in the rear view mirror now
we've gotta now we've just got to sweep
up the last ten thousand and that is a
fixed amount that is not going anywhere
got it we've locked in we've locked in
our losses is they're not going to get
worse the story's not going to drag out
it's over now kill the 10 000 bucks and
it's really over right that's why I went
there so fast
you got it just pay the stupid tax and
be done yeah got it yeah yeah okay and
actually what I've learned to tell
myself is I'm not even paying the stupid
tax there
I'm just admitting it
because I've already paid it when the
thing went down in value through that
yeah and so yeah I've already I've
already made the mistake all I'm doing
is admitting it when I sell it so that's
powerful well done yeah they're willing
to sell off some things to get this done
that's exciting our stupid toys she said
yep and uh man people got some stupid
toys yeah and listeners we're not
against toys
we're against stupid toy at the wrong
time Uncle what's a stupid toy stupid
toys one you have Dead on
listen I one guy told me he said I that
my bass boat and I'm like dude your bass
boat is 550 a month
and I made him sit down we're doing a
small group at a Financial Peace
University I made him sit down and add
up
how many bass he caught a year and what
the average pounds were and we divided
out that those bass were costing him
something like 160 bucks a pound by the
time he got him home that's hilarious
you know dude this is this is freaking
Beluga caviar here it's just like this
is not Bass
that is hilarious so it's not don't tell
me you're feeding your family please
okay please don't tell me that all right
it's nothing wrong with a bass boat I
don't have a bass boat but I got a
couple Master crafts and I got Sea-Doos
and all this other crap but I paid cash
for them and they're going down in value
and they're the top of the line best of
everything and I love them and they're
toys yeah and they're a small percentage
of my world so stupid toys are Toys that
are a large percentage of your world uh
or that you have payments on or both
right and I've done stupid toys as many
as Kelsey probably
um or maybe even more but I've also done
toys the right way and then they don't
bother me
you're into that because you know we
talk we know what that means when it
comes to cars right we don't pay cash
for a brand new car until we're a
Millionaire right and then there's
people who want to get boats and
Sea-Doos and campers so explain to the
people
what's what's too much and when they can
do all that and how they can do all that
without getting ridiculous uh I use a
couple of rules
um rule number one I use is the total of
everything you own with motors and
wheels
campers Wheels no motor boats Motors no
wheels right all that but Motors or
Wheels all those things go down in value
and the total of all those things you
own should never be more than half your
annual income
should be a small percentage of your
world the second rule I use is if I set
fire to it and it had no insurance
does it change my life financially am I
am I financially devastated because the
item I just completely blew that amount
of money because in essence you're
blowing that amount of money right it
needs to be like a friend of mine's a
billionaire and he bought like a four
hundred thousand dollar car for him for
him buying that it's like most of us
buying a biscuit right right so change
it needs to be a non-issue in the
mathematics he could burn that car to
the ground once a week and it won't
change his life all right so that's the
point it's a non-issue but people buying
crap to make to make themselves look
good or to be big dogs they're always
the broke people right I was I'm driving
a jaguar and only the money put gas in
it you know back when I was broke yeah
and so that we've all done that stuff so
that's where you break the cycle Jade
washer good show today
Austin Ben James Zach and Andrew in the
booth the booth dudes that make this
happen that puts this hour the Ramsay
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
heard in this episode and want to know
more about getting started on the Ramsay
baby steps go to ramsesolutions.com and
click the get started button we'll help
you figure out the best next step for
you based on your specific situation
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]